if it's coming why fear it embrace it
monetize oh god that was crazy
oh [ __ ]
did you invent pause yes wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute i know this
i am the inventor so you were the
inventor of paws my crew the best out we
invented pause for sure
because nobody could ever ever say that
i didn't no that's all of us that came
from my block
period my crew best out
what year was this how far are we going
about remember when did the po are we
going like 80 obviously the 80s early
90s
[Music]
no [ __ ] no
bugging that's when you found out about
it yeah yeah it was a secret society
no one knew about paws for like 20 years
bro
and then all of a sudden i was like oh
[ __ ] me kids saying i'd be like you know
i invented that baby right now you did
it you tell me the rules i'd be like my
son hits me with the pause at least once
a week yeah and also i invented i made
up the term fresh to death
i go say that listen i pop tags i made
that one up okay i i i'm the one that
named hover i made that up
i made that up
what was the inspiration for the hover
because jehovah you know
but but but pause we're gonna get back
to the pause because this is more the
more iconic canceled out here bro i
understand that it's probably not the
most uh you know
it's not meant to be offensive it's
always been a personal joke with my
friends and now the whole world does it
it's like [ __ ] i can't even have a
[ __ ] personal joke you know
everyone's like people would ask me i'd
be like i would never tell them what it
meant ever i'd be like you have to
figure it out but no one knew what it
meant because if you say what it means i
think about this just show a [ __ ]
clip of me in the history of any part of
the world
at any time that i didn't say pause
were you saying pause
bro
don't understand
in harlem it don't matter how much money
you got
it don't matter what you're doing
if you slip [ __ ] are laughing hard
if i do some dumb [ __ ]
it's like instagram they just i'm
because i'm so like
you know yeah so you're catching me
slipping it's a celebration
like i don't even think i lost a snap
fight in like 100 years you know what
i'm saying can you remember one of the
more funniest like
moments in paw's history
yeah the one with you just now that was
one of the funniest ones because i feel
like maybe
yeah
you know you you okay